let's have some matrix a
so it's an n by k matrix and i have the
equation a
x is equal to b so in this case x
x would have to be a member of rk of rk
because we have k columns here and b
is a member of rn
now let's say that it just so happens
that there is no solution so there is no
solution
there is no solution to
ax is equal to b
what does that mean
if let's just expand out a just to i
think you already know what that means
if i write a like this a1 a2 if i just
write it as its column vectors right
there all the way through ak
and then i multiply it times x1
x2 all the way to through xk
this is the same thing as that equation
there i just kind of wrote out the two
matrices now this is the same thing as
x1 times a1 plus x2 times a2
all the way to
plus xk times ak
is equal to the vector b
now if we have if this has no solution
then that means that there's no set of
weights here
on the column vectors of a where we can
get to b or another way to say it is no
linear combinations of the column
vectors of a will be equal to b or an
even a further way of saying it is that
b
is not
in
the column space of a no linear
combination of these guys can equal to
that so let's see if we can visualize it
a bit so let me draw the column space of
a
so maybe the column space of a looks
something like this right here
i'll just assume it's a plane in rn
it doesn't have to be a plane things can
be very general but let's say this is
the column space
this is the column space of a
now if that's the column space and b is
not in the comp space maybe we can draw
b like this
maybe b let's say this is the origin
right there and b just pops out right
there this is the zero vector this is my
vector b clearly not in my column space
it's clearly not in this plane now up
until now we would you know we would get
an equation like that we would get make
an augmented matrix put in reduced row
echelon form and get a line that said
zero equals one and we say no solution
nothing we can do here but what if we
can do better what if we can you know we
clearly can't find a solution to this
but what if we can find a solution that
gets us close to this
so what if
i want to find some x
i'll call it x star for now
where so i want to find some x star
where
where a times x star
is and this is a vector this is a vector
is
as
close
close as possible
let me write this as close
to
b
as possible
or another way to view it when i say
close i'm talking about length so i want
to minimize
i want to minimize the length of let me
write this down i want to minimize
minimize
the length of
b
minus a times x star
a times x star
now some of y'all might already know
where this is going but when you take
when you take the difference between two
and then take its length what does that
look like what does that look like let
me just call ax
ax is going to be a member of my column
space let me just call that v ax is
equal to v since we're taking some
linear you multiply any vector in rk
times the columns of x times your matrix
a you're going to get a member of your
column space
so any ax is going to be
is going to be in your column space so
any ax is going to be in your column
space and maybe that is
the vector v is equal to a times x star
we want this vector to get as close as
possible to this as pos
as long as it stays i mean it has to be
in my column space but we want this is
the distance between this vector and
this vector to be minimized now i just
want to show you where the terminology
for this will come from i haven't given
it its proper title yet
if you were to take this vector i'm
saying that this is let's just call this
vector v for simplicity that this is
equivalent to
the length of the vector
of the vector you take the difference
between each of the elements so b1 minus
v1 v2
minus v2
all the way to b
n
minus vn
and if you take the length of this
vector this is the same thing as this
this is going to be equal to
the square root let me take the length
squared actually the length squared of
this is just going to be v1 minus v1
squared plus
b2 minus v2 squared plus all the way to
bn minus vn squared and i want to
minimize this so i want to make this
value the least value that it can be
possible i want to get the least squares
estimate here and that's why
i this last minute or two when i was
just explaining this that was just to
give you the motivation for why this
right here is called the least squares
estimate
least
squares
least squares estimate
or the least squares solution or the
least squares approximation for the
equation ax equal b there is no solution
to this but maybe we can find some x
star where if i multiply a times x star
this is going to be this is clearly
going to be in my column space and i
want to get this vector to be as close
to b as possible
now we've already seen in several videos
what is the closest vector in my in any
subspace to a vector that's not in my
subspace well the closest vector to it
is the projection
the closest vector to b that's in my
subspace is going to be
the
projection of b
onto my column space
that is the closest vector there so if i
want to minimize if i want to minimize
this
i'm essentially i want to figure out i
want to figure my x star where a
x star
is equal to
is equal to the projection
of my vector b
onto my subspace or onto the column
space of a
remember what we're doing here we said
axb has no solution but maybe we can
find some x that gets us as close as
possible so that i'm calling that my
least squares solution or my least
squares approximation and
this guy right here is clearly going to
be in my column space right because you
take some vector x times a that's going
to be a linear combination of these
column vectors so it's going to be in
the column space and i want this guy
to be as close as possible to this guy
would be as close as possible that guy
well the closest vector in my column
space to that guy is the projection so i
want so ax needs to be equal to the
projection of b on my column space
it needs to be equal to that
but this is still pretty hard to find
you know to find that you saw how you
know you take a times the inverse of a
transpose a times a transpose that it's
hard to find that transformation matrix
so let's see if we can find an easier
way to figure out
the least squares solution or kind of
our best solution it's not the solution
it's our best solution to this right
here that's what we call the least
squares solution or approximation
so if we
let's just subtract b from both sides of
this and we'll we might get something
interesting
so what happens if we if we take ax
minus the vector b on both sides of this
equation i'll do it up here on the right
so if we on the left hand side we get a
times x star it's hard to write the x
and then the star because they're very
similar and then we subtract b from it
we subtract our vector b that's going to
be equal to
the projection
the projection of b onto
our column space
minus b all i did is i subtracted b from
both sides of this equation
now what is the projection of b
minus our vector b
if we draw it right here it's going to
be this vector right let me do it in let
me do it in this orange color
it's going to be this right here it's
going to be that vector right there
right if i take the projection of b
which is that
minus b i'm going to get this vector or
you could say b
plus this vector is equal to my
projection of b onto my subspace so this
vector right here is orthogonal it's
actually part of the definition of a of
a projection that this guy
this guy is going to be orthogonal to my
subspace or to my column space and so
this guy
is orthogonal to my column space so i
could write
i can write
a
x star
minus b it's orthogonal to my column
space or we could say it's a member of
the orthogonal complement of my column
space
right the orthogonal complement is just
the set of everything the set of
everything all of the vectors that are
orthogonal to everything in your
subspace in your column space right here
so this this vector right here this kind
of pointing straight down onto my plane
is clearly a member of the orthogonal
complement of my column space now we've
this might look familiar to you already
what is the orthogonal complement of my
column space the orthogonal complement
of my column space
is equal to
the null space
of a
transpose
right or the left null space of a we've
done this in many many videos so we can
say
we can say that a
times my least squares estimate of the
equation ax is equal to b i wrote that
so x star is my least squares solution
to ax is equal to b so a times that
minus b
minus b is a member of the null space of
a transpose
now what does that mean
well that means that if i multiply a
transpose
if i multiply a transpose times this guy
right here
times
a
x star and let me no i don't want to
lose the vector signs there on the x
this is a vector i don't want to forget
that a x star
minus b
so if i multiply a transpose times this
right there that is the same thing as
that what am i going to get well this is
a member of the null space of a
transpose so this times a transpose has
got to be equal to zero it is a solution
to a transpose times something is equal
to
is equal to the zero vector
now let's see if we can simplify this a
little bit
we get
a transpose a transpose a
times
x star
times x star
minus
a
transpose
b
is equal to zero and then if we add this
term to both sides of the equation
we are left with
we are left with a
transpose a times the least squares
solution
the least square solution to ax equal to
b
is equal to
a
transpose
b
that's what we get
now why did we do all this work remember
what we started with we said we're
trying to find a solution to a x
is equal to b
but there was no solution there was
no solution
so we said well let's find at least an x
star let's at least find an x star
that
that minimizes
b that minimizes the distance between b
and a
x star and we call that that we call
this the least square solution we call
it a least square solution because when
you actually take the length or actually
or when you're minimizing the length
you're minimizing the squares of the
differences right there so it's the
least squares solution
now we
to find this we know that this has to be
the closest vector in our subspace 2v
to be and we know that the closest
vector in our subspace to 2b is the
projection
of b onto our subspace onto our column
space of a
and so we know that
we know that a let me switch colors
we know that a
times our least square solution
should be equal to the projection
the projection
of b
onto the column space of a if we can
find some x in rk that satisfies this
that is our least square solution but
we've seen before that this the
projection b is easier said than done as
you know there's a lot of work to it so
maybe we can do it a simpler way and
this is our simpler way if we can if we
if we're looking for this
alternately we could just find a
solution to this equation so you give me
an ax equal to b
there is no solution well what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to multiply both
sides of this equation times a transpose
if i multiply both sides of this
equation by a transpose i get a
transpose
times
ax
ax is equal to
a transpose now i want to do that the
same blue
a no that's not the same blue
a
transpose
b
all i did is i multiplied both sides of
this now this solution this solution is
not going to be the solution to this
equation will not be the same as the
solution to this equation
this right here will always have a
solution and this right here is our
least squares solution
so this right here is our least squares
solution and notice
this is some matrix and then this right
here
is some vector this right here is some
vector so as long as we can find a
solution here we've given our best shot
at finding a solution to ax equals b
we've minimized the error we're going to
get ax star and the difference between a
x star and b is going to be minimized
it's going to be our least square
solution it's all a little bit abstract
right now in this video but hopefully in
the next video we'll we'll realize that
it's actually a very very useful concept